klein et parce qu'il dit que vous aviez
dit dans à l'état sauvage que en fait
voilà vous étiez la vraie shy'm voilà
mais c'est pas ça c'est qu'elle s'est
découvert pourquoi il s'est passé pas
j'ai toujours pendant ma carrière vécu
entre entre ce personnage que j'ai créé
et une la femme que je suis dans la vie
de tous les jours qui ressemblait à deux
gouttes d'eau à celle que j'étais dans
high school parce que vous avez cru
c'est un personnage c'est ce que
j'explique un peu dans l'est dans les
portraits avant avant l'émission c'est
un de discrètes
oui pardon à salles la femme de sel est
nativement wiki et décomplexée de rêve
de fantasmes que je ne pourrais pas
réalisé dans ma vie tous les jours et ça
paraît peut-être un peu incohérent et
improbable pour dire qu'il ne le vis pas
mais moi ce de pousser ce personnel à
l'extrême m'aide à l'assumer sur scène
mais effectivement il ressemble peu à la
femme que je suis dans la vie de tous
les jours et et c'est vrai que pour le
coup je ça fait 12 ans que je j'encaisse
la critique qu'elle soit négative ou
positive et ça fait partie de cette
villa et j'ai beaucoup de recul avec ça
et jokin social entendre et c'est vrai
que là d'entente ce mot hypocrisie sur
en plus cette émission sur ce film et
cette aventure en fait avant tout ça m'a
piqué autrement en fait 20 mai pic
souvent épiques souvent non mais c'est
alors vous avez compris sa réponse bien
sûr moi j'entends parfaitement
moi je juge en tant que téléspectateur
j'ai été choqué parce que j'ai
l'impression que vous méprise y est tous
les gens qui avaient acheté vos 10
environ à 10 ans maintenant c'est la
vraie chaleur moi je traduis le plateau
et mes émotions
donc je continuerai à les traduire en
compterait au contraire je pense qu'il
n'y avait pas de mépris de shine dans
l'émission c'était j'étais heureuse en
fait de me dévoiler tel que j'étais à
presque 32 ans et j'étais prête à le
faire maintenant et au contraire comme
je me je nourris l'artistique jeu tamara
nourish à une tous les jours évidemment
que j'ai besoin de ces deux femmes là
entre guillemets j'ai besoin de cet
équilibre et ça m'a quand même fait du
bien malgré lui un stress énorme ça m'a
fait du bien de montrer tels que je suis
quand même mais je viens pas ça je vous
dis que j'ai hâte de me retrouver sur
scène que j'ai ador trois années que
l'on trouvait encore plus épanouie et
heureuse dans ce contexte là où va ce
que les torts c'est très bien de
répondre je continue
mais ça s'est entendu dire ici
ah oui mais j'aurais pas mais
effectivement il n'a mais c'est fou
d'être à ce point cynique et de penser
systématiquement non cynique des
quelqu'un a fait quelque chose c'est
forcément pour des raisons commerciales
machin nana passé c'est qu'elle va sinon
sûr que citoyens qui comme ça tu
reproche aux autres que tu es vraiment
est quelqu'un de cyniques à deux têtes
et tu triches êtes sûrs porte sur shine
que j'adore tes autour autour pitié de
tes propres turpitudes
devenu le vrai s'est présenté des
excuses à cette jeune fille que tu as
récemment levé la perruque au fait c'est
vrai du coup j'ai pu même pas crédible
une société attend jamais supprimé le
peut alors oui gilles c'est pas de leur
mot qui va me donner des leçons de
morale en fait pour toi courage
surgériens pas du tout fait j'ai pas à
présenter mes excuses puisque je suis la
main sur 10 ans avait pas les couilles
je suis moi même et non comme vous vous
n'aurez jamais dire ce que vous pensez
au nom d'intérêts d'autres intérêts moi
je suis sincère donc après ça peut
choquer mais j'ai pas à présenter
d'excusés 6 étoiles et agressivité de
crédit de dire qu'il n'a rien fait elle
n'est pas naturelle
enfin pendant ces années là elle a créé
ce personnage ou l'accepter après elle a
le droit de devenir ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui à tous jacky à une évolution
avec tout le monde soit ce que tu es
aujourd'hui sur le plateau tulipes à
l'extérieur tu es malheureusement il
n'est pas comme ça c'est pas le même il
aurait vu prévu dans le métro comme ça